a candidate for mayor of New Orleans has
been accused of masturbating in the
backseat of his Oberer ride this is a
true story yeah yes yes isn't that
insane I was thinking about this I was
thinking what kind of sad sick creep
would masturbate while riding in someone
else's car it makes no sense to just
[Applause]
Billy wait a minute what just happened
Billy why don't you just cut to that guy
in the crowd
sorry caught in my bed okay I'm really
sorry that's incredibly that was effed
up that was inappropriate sorry anyway
the reason I bring up this backseat
masturbator this creep is that the
galaxy Billy you cut to that guy again
yeah it's this new console that we have
the camera three button is where the
camera one button used to be so
sometimes I want to stay on camera one
and I hit the camera three it's a
hodgepodge I don't care it's a
hodgepodge just get it together sir I
apologize that's incredibly
unprofessional I'm sorry anyway
this total pervert is running for public
office okay who I'm just thinking who
would jeopardize his protocol here
political career just to rub one out in
the backseat of some uber it makes no
sense for a yeah
Billy is this about the arms yes it's
about the arms what the hell is that
that's a clip left over from the sketch
we did called this guy well that old
sketch which idiot thought of that one
this guy it's a long time ago I cannot
apologize enough I am very very sorry
sir
I like to spank the monkey in an uber
[Applause]
[Music]
Billy sorry Conan the button to not do
that is where the button to do that used
to be so naturally stop Billy stop keep
your hands off the console completely
just push your chair away from the
console and let me talk
[Music]
snapping
here comes the egg
[Applause]
sorry wrong way wrong button place
you